Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We're currently more than 130 episodes into
the series, and we still haven't talked about
this algorithm.
How could we go on for so long without PatchMatch?
So, let's do this right now!
You'll love this one.
This technique helps us to make absolutely
crazy modifications to previously existing
photographs and it is one of the landmark
papers for all kinds of photo manipulation
which is still widely used to this day.
Consider the following workflow: we have this
image as an input.
Let's mark the roofline for hole filling,
or image inpainting as the literature refers
to it.
And the hole is now filled with quite sensible
information.
Now we mark some of the pillars to reshape
the object.
And then, we pull the roof upward.
The output is a completely redesigned version
of the input photograph.
Wow, absolutely incredible.
And the whole thing happens interactively,
almost in real time, but if we consider the
hardware improvement since this paper was
published, it is safe to say that today it
runs in real time even on a mediocre computer.
And in this piece of work, the image completion
part works by adding additional hints to the
algorithm, for instance, marking the expected
shape of an object that we wish to cut out
and have it filled in with new data.
Or, showing the shape of the building that
we wish to edit also helps the technique considerably.
These results are so stunning, I remember
that when I had first seen them, I had to
recheck over and over again because I could
hardly believe my eyes.
This technique offers not only these high
quality results, but it is considerably quicker
than its competitors.
To accomplish image inpainting, most algorithms
look for regions in the image that are similar
to the one that is being removed, and borrow
some information from there for the filling
process.
Here, one of the key ideas that speed up the
process is that when good correspondances
are found, if we are doing another lookup,
we shouldn't restart the patch matching process,
but we should try to search nearby, because
that's where we are most likely to find useful
information.
You know what the best part is?
What you see here is just the start: this
technique does not use any of the modern machine
learning techniques, so in the era of these
incredibly powerful deep neural networks,
I can only imagine the quality of solutions
we'll be able to obtain in the near future.
We are living amazing times indeed.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!